sometimes to make a sick play you just
got to forget the scope and pull the
trigger that's right we are counting
down the top ten no scopes in cs:go
history pit kicks off our list in style
with two insane Scout shots winter fox
might have lost the round but hit one
our heart a bomb site
Paul Sean is missing that flick and
Pitts find a double there nice jump
Scout onto Shaw that's got to be an
insult to injury
JDM snatches are number nine spot for
this ridiculous clutch thanks to
back-to-back noscopes including a slick
180 spin it's an impossible shot that
makes no sense which means that fall
into crazy wolf a noscope deserves
number eight on the list
okay well but that I don't even know it
was it seems like JW is at his best when
he plays with no respect and in their
pick for number seven caps off a quad
kill with a pair of nasty nose goes does
he drop down know what is the sickest
pure reaction shot no scopez comes in at
number six that's right it's fallens
insane clutch from IM Katowice tags up
because he's gonna take
our pick for number five is quite
possibly the longest range professional
nose goes from nearly one end of long to
the others but to start to learn fluffs
is line
screw the scope you rinse it off the off
trout Scout noscope makes the list at
number four not only because it but for
nothing's absolutely hilarious reaction
unreal in a pig for number three
Kenny s shows off his skills with an
absolutely insane
double-a noscope clutch how did he even
win this round comes Kenny s oh my god
Kenny s with three insane kills and he
has time wait are you telling me he's
gonna win the route has he got time yeah
he's got home unbelievable okay I said
let's go and kill everyone else but no
Kenny has finally turns up that's 15
with the most redonkulous no scopes i
have seen in a very long time we
couldn't possibly do a noscope list
without including simples fallin off in
the top to the play the casting and even
the crowd reaction everything is perfect
sit double smokes in the same place
this is the FBO this is a major the
simple either no minor peach comes in
with a major saving moment one of the
best plays in csgo history and it's a
jumping double noscope with another
noscope for style cold Sara's legendary
jumping off deserves nothing less than
number one the first face is attorneys
gonna hit the ground there's cold on the
same luminosity with your plain
unthinkable seeds they're on the bee
apartments they need a huge play without
something I'm never gonna see ever again
ridiculous stuff there are so many great
no scopes but we couldn't possibly put
them all on the list so we want to know
which one was your favorite let us know
in the comments section below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button